oh no [ __ ] [ __ ] tyonne oh they're both
really good I'm trying to talk back into
my child and I'm just coming up with
like bad middle school memories well I
think this tastes like heaven because
thinman's are my favorite girl scout
cookies of all time Oh
four days [ __ ] dead men's there's like
that minty kick to it
hmm no no the chocolate is more
synthetic this inside is just like
chalky I think this one's a tenant what
we're right I know we're right you don't
need to tell me I'm right I know I'm
right all right for right did they teach
you that the correct way to eat a
tag-along in the girl scouts the way I
ate it was I ate all the chocolate first
and then I would like the peanut butter
out and then I would eat the cookie this
is a good ratio between the peanut
butter and chocolate
daka's stale no hmm the peanut butter is
like a little more chalky whereas this
one's creamier this one's more of a
wafer this one's the tag along I'm gonna
go with the dark in the middle too whoo
by the looks of it they look almost
identical I would say that the only
thing different is that duck darkness
and chocolate a little look good from
the circle where did this circle you
know no merit badge here oh [ __ ] that
photo I like this one a little bit more
no it just really can't tell anything
anymore I wait all year for the Girl
Scout cookies and now knowing that like
I can't tell the difference is like
pretty crushing to me I think those ones
are real too would like what I'm gonna
I'm going right yeah my team leader
would be so pissed at me
this was great I love hard yeah I'm
surprised that I got this no is wrong
for these I knew OS keeper all the best
cookies are delivered by tiny people I
think after this I can say that I will
buy any of the grocery store versions
besides equipment those fake Tagalongs
was fake alongs really good I feel like
I would rather buy the Girl Scout cookie
so I could contribute and be part of
this really amazing thing that has so
much history now I feel bad